[Music]
you're a blessing Mr Clay this place was
crab grass and weeds and you brought it
back to
life Mrs Parker and I were friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this hist the is shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counted three one two
three there I did it for
you you take it I'm going to burn this
place to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is his is a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have laws for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers he cut him off what the
[__] bro
don't
move
down this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scan the money is going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem God damn
right I'm a
problem
no way he's coming here straight through
the black entrance I figured i' give the
firefighters a break somebody detain
this
guy we have to kill him before he kills
his way to the
top
honey it's flammable as [__] who
knew
you're going
get General we are
discovered
good
wait guys it's a CL
rre
I'm not built like other
mens in
mes move along now those in power only
see me as a Gro unfit for higher
office just like witches at
black but I follow in the footsteps of
Alexander the Great and Caesar evil
minds at plot destruction if you look
down you'll see a surprise
once you see it you will always want it
Sorcerer of death
construction I must warn you I will not
lead a second in
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it at top my own
[Music]
head you want to be great but you are
nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
were all sleep again without This
Vermin whose country are we in
[Music]
mine I certainly hope you dance as well
as you
dress there's only one way to find
out on
Dan the you and I we're not so different
agent
AR it'll help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Ellie it's called a
copout
whoa hey there's a cat in
there oh my God you're Ellie freaking
Conway author of AR series ell Conway I
am such a fan oh yeah what is it you do
Espionage would you sign my
book here we
go I love this
book
come
[Music]
on who are these people real life spies
why would they care about me because
you're a goddamn Fortune tiller
Ellie what you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you kicked a
hornets nest you didn't even know
existed I'm in some really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next
chapter God I hate that
[Music]
cat it's time for you to meet the real
agent our
guy oh my God oh my God oh my
God I was a
fighter I ain't
anymore what kind of price you got on me
kind that'll get you chased down no
matter where you go
I had your money big mama so is it I
lost it you only way for you to get rep
paid is the oldfashioned way fight or
don't fight you might get hurt if you
do you will get hurt if you
[Music]
don't just take it I don't want it it's
the type of money that can change
somebody's life son of a gun the butcher
standing right here in front of me after
all these years you still figh
yeah the lady at the store said you were
a fighter that right once upon a time
why do you have to fight tonight long
story you ain't no good to me this but
you going give me a fight you in a big
hole have got bigger when you started
dancing around Big Mama's Street you
can't fight there's
not you don't got to do this it's going
to be all
right there is this great big world out
there and sometimes it spins against
you but sometimes it spins you right
into what you
need I can't tell you what you want to
hear that guy will kill you but I'm not
leaving
you you used to be hell but
hell has caught
[Applause]
up yeah
it's going to be a bad one come
on you don't look capable no more
capable of
what Carol danas prodical child of the
Milky
Way Nick Fury my favorite oneeyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there you know
cold no air space
[Applause]
Captain Marvel the
annihilator you took everything from
me and now I'm returning the
[Music]
favor
what is happening to
me she's entangled our light based
Powers so we switch places whenever we
use
them strong Theory you can absorb
light I can see it and Camala who's
Camala hi she can turn light into
physical matter which I have never heard
of I could totally show you
no
you you s around
make be you
down first St
[Music]
profile she's targeting every planet we
call
[Music]
home I would never choose to bring
anybody into this you are not the only
thing standing between this and the
universe oh my God we're a team if you
want to B goat
[Music]
higher
further
[Music]
faster who's a good kitty
Goose oh my
God I can't can you I got
it
[Music]
shots fired shots fired all units please
respond
[Music]
no
this
the
[Music]
minus
one Mr just
snow after everything you've seen out
there in the
world what are the Hunger Games for are
you are
[Music]
you the Hunger Games they to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles not
survivors we're
live smile it's why we have
teeth imagine it was your name that they
B
strange I just want to know that
somebody still cared about me that I was
still of
value welcome to the capital you look
like you shouldn't be here I shouldn't
but I'm your Mentor a
rebel I am going to get you out of here
you want to protect
people and it's essential to accept what
human beings
are what it takes to control
them let's see you use that famous snow
charm do you seem like a good man Corina
snow I have seen what war does to
people fueled with the terve becoming
prey see how quickly we become
Predators I want my enemies to see a
rainbow of
Destruction engulfing the
world your monsters all of
you good luck with that poor little song
bird where is
she it's mystery and Mysteries have a
way of driving people
mad
Mr snow let me ask you one final time
what are the Hunger Games
for
[Music]
hang it's the things we love most that
destroy
us
for
[Music]
foreign
speech
foree
spee
fore
[Music]
for Fore
spee
when the war
started they protected
me they better care of me than humans
would
have than our people
Maya
it's just
programming 10 years ago today the
artificial intelligence created to
protect us detonated a nuclear warhead
in Los
Angeles this is a fight for our very
existence Sergeant Taylor we are this
close to winning the
war but the AI are developing a super
weapon retrieve
it
or they win
[Music]
to did you locate the weapon yeah it's
just a
kit are you going to heaven
no you got to be a good person to go to
heaven then we're the say we can't go to
heaven cuz you're not
good and I'm not a
person
do you have any idea what that thing is
she looks like a little girl now but
she's
growing Whoever has that kid wins the
war this side you want
huh what do you want sweetie for robots
to be
free oh we don't have that in the fridge
how about ice
cream
ever since I was a child people said my
family was
cursed mom tried to protect us with
God pop tried to protect us with
wrestling he said if we were the
toughest the strongest nothing could'
ever hurt
us I believed him we all
did morning pants tomorrow pleas
David Harry I want you to join your
brothers in the ring yes sir I love that
now we all know Carrie's my favorite
then Kev then David then Mike but the
rankings can always change what do you
want in last Kevin ER more ribs I want
to be with my family you know be with my
brothers what do you like to do with
your
brothers Harry and
David
together we can do
anything we're here to restore Justice
to the Wrestling Federation that our
father built with his own two hands the
hands that were passed down to us the
hands that will deliver the iron claw to
you so what do you think like we're aive
I love your family
Kev you going to be an uncle yes sir oh
man that makes me so happy I talk to you
about something all Dad's too tough on
us you got to say something maybe that's
what your brothers are for you feel that
you feel that that's
pressure me you're pushing too hard I'm
fine kid seriously I'm just
sick God I'm scared man and all my had
of
control was a terrible accident I should
have stopped him I need to think about
my family your job is to wrestle live up
to that deal or we are through I told
look out for I just love being out there
with you guys it's the only thing that
matters to me the will forever be the
greatest family in the history of
[Applause]
[Music]
wrestl
go
[Applause]
[Music]
jonus we need your
help we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25,000 ft deep in the
trench it's an ancient ecosystem
Untouched by man whatever is down there
is trying to make its way to the
surface this is a bad idea just a little
bit
[Music]
Jas we've got
company that's the biggest Meg I've ever
seen biggest Meg anyone's everever
St that's the apex
predator everybody back get station you
can make it
keep three massive legs and who knows
what else have escape the
breach I just hope it goes better than
last
time what happened last
time you don't want to
[Applause]
know go go go we never seen this before
they hunted him
back
we can relax this place Meg proof I mean
Jonas was always afraid of this but I
was also
thinking I bet you going to
EMP you have down down down
down ooh
barracuda
[Music]
4 years ago I was basically
unemployed a Wanderer with no
home but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way I'm know how do pops my job was a
little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of
[Music]
Atlantis half a billion people from
every known species in the sea call this
place
home but that doesn't mean they all like
[Applause]
me I'm going to kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds
deal I'm going to murder his
family and earn his kingdom to
Ash he must be stopped for a global
meltdown is
imminent I think I know someone in my go
to help
us you look
rough good job little brother High fire
do not call me
brother I cannot believe you let this
happen yeah well I hate this job true
king buil build Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges we need to find Manta he's
different now he's stronger than
before it's the black
Trident during King alin's time there
were Seven
Kingdoms and the Trident was a curse
upon them
all the tridon start magic is
spreading he means to end the
[Music]
bloodline I don't know what lies ahead
but we can't leave our children a world
without
hope you're not as bad at this as you
thank
you if you lead the Seven Kingdoms will
[Music]
follow
[Applause]
my son never show
Mercy they are
pray we are predators
Bo your mother is
dead she died because you sent her away
she was weak sick in her mind you know
my business
yes power is about
strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemies an
opening shoot
shoot
he's weak like his mother leave
him what happened that
day I stared death in the face and for
the first time I saw my true
self tell me about this
Hunter they say he uses a connection
with animals to track his
prey want on his
list there's only one way off there six
of us and only one of you there's six of
you
[Music]
now why do you hunt my father put evil
into the
world I take it
[Music]
out I think you have some kind of Honor
you are exactly like our father just
another man hunting for a
trophy we're
murderers isn't that what he taught
us you don't get to do that to me
anymore Mr
tlan Mr
tlin where's Mr tlin oh you're standing
in
him you're goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out now
there is an animal in each one of us
don't you want to know why they call me
the
rhino
[Applause]
[Music]
what on Earth
we need a plan Tony can we liven it up
Freddy drop a beat
yes nice Shield cap you too
cap you dance but of course Let's Dance
for
smash who are you I'm The Collector
behold my
collection when you get to be as big a
deal as I am it's all about rare one of
a kind but it's still not enough that's
why I've decided to collect Avengers
take
[Music]
them anyone have any ideas we need
someone with special skills no not that
guy he's the best at what he does and
what he does isn't very nice
guess I'm not going to get to eat my
lunch Mom's Diner that's just adorable
it's probably a death trap oh
boy activate scan and sword functions
two animals excuse
me we're going to build our way
out it's time to collect a little
payback
now you are going to be impressed by
[Music]
this th buddy uh-oh I overdressed ah
better change no no R
it
nice hey thanks for coming come on let
her in she's lost a lot of
blood no idea and had multiple
aerations he's
[Music]
coming I'm with Social Services I'm not
going to hurt you do you know who did
this to
you anything on that girl last night let
us do our
jobs girls have been disappearing around
for
years
this place never
disappoints What If there really is
someone out there killing lots of
them what are you feeling that
me women get reported missing all the
time hey and most of them turn out to be
nothing be
ready these type of situations lost
calls stay the [__] out of my job there
were some [__] asking just a lot of
questions feed
down je so beautiful you hear the music
you just couldn't leave it alone could
you I just need a little more
time darling this is your
salvation
[Music]
a